before we even start i want to show you
something we had no idea
what this movie would be when we first
started
on the on the on the first picture it
was kind of like the little movie that
could
um it's it's just snowballed into this
this out of control thing and uh you
know now we have two
two uh sequels we have the the hockey
team we have uh
the saturday morning cartoon and maybe
uh maybe a live action series now it's
kind of nutty but it's cool when you
first started this
what did you did you have any idea
no i mean you just never know how
that picture is going to turn out is it
going to stand the test of time is it
going to transcend
across generations you just you just
never know and the fact that
it was a little movie that could we made
it two sequels
a hockey franchise i mean like i said
you know in 1996
it was crazy absolutely crazy
i'm gordon bombay i'm the new coach
now here's the long and the short of it
i hate hawking i don't like kids
they call you and they say hey do you
want to let's bring gordon back to life
let's get them going what is your first
reaction when you get that phone call
it's interesting because you know i kind
of left mainstream movies
and you and i have talked over the years
it's like i left mainstream movies
with the with mighty ducks three and
that same year i did
mission impossible one and then i went
off and directed my own
thing and did my what i like to call my
time in the wilderness
where i was making independent films
sort of on my own time
at my own pace to come back now to
mainstream
and coming back by way of mighty ducks
game changers it feels organic it feels
like it was like almost like a plan
it wasn't but it almost it almost feels
like it
and it feels like a real natural and
organic thing to do in order to be a
team
you just have to have a home rank and a
coach
what about gordon bombay gordon bombay
gordon bombay
i'm guessing you didn't see the sign i
hate hockey and i don't like kids
you run an ice rink weird huh have you
been skating all this time
have you been staying on the so what was
that
painful because you know the older you
get
the longer it takes to heal yes you fall
it happens very quickly and you know you
get over on that
off that edge or you get too far on that
edge and off you go
i'm an avid snowboarder and so i i and i
took off from snowboarding for like i
don't know 10 years
when i got back on i was like boom i was
cutting
my edges were i mean i was making
beautiful turns i thought
skating is going to be the same way no
problem but
first day boom boom i mean it was i was
in so much pain
every day skating it's uh and i had to
break in new skates which is not
advisable
so yeah it was tough it was tough i
spent my entire life
chasing hockey and i have absolutely
nothing to show for it
you have us how was it working with
lauren and bringing her into this
franchise and now on youtube it seems
like we'll be together as this show goes
on
i had to make an adjustment because this
is my first tv series
you know normally with a movie you go
into it and like you see all 120 pages
and you know right right i'm shooting
this i'm shooting that and
with the tv show obviously lauren is a
seasoned pro i mean she's been doing
this for a long time and she had
obviously a hell of a lot more
experience than i did working in this
format
and i would go to her every day i was
like man i don't understand
it's like uh what's happening in the
next episode and we're just getting this
script and then
and what happens in episode 10 and she's
like listen
relax it's all going to work out and so
she was
in many ways like a mentor for me in in
terms of learning the landscape of this
television process
so i was grateful for that
guys don't get discouraged okay that's
why we watch game tape to get better
it's like a master class
in second how much fun were the kids
because i sway apparently was the tick
tock queen and she like led the charge
with the tick tocks and everything like
that and you and lauren are big social
media people so what was that like
no in fact in fact i had to take the the
twitter machine
was taken away from me during a ducks
blackhawks game
uh and i started you know bourbon was
involved
and uh and i started yelling at the
chicago team
and then the fans jumped on me and so
yeah i had to
i had to stop the social media of it all
but what was interesting with the kids
is that you know because of kovid we
weren't able to
socialize we weren't able to really dig
in and get to know each other and have
social time either on set or or even
offset
like when the first couple of mighty
ducks keenan thompson talked about
how when we were doing part two you know
he said emilio
has rented this go-kart track for us in
bowling alley and we did all this stuff
and
and he didn't know any of us but those
are the things you do
when you are trying to create a team and
you're trying to create a social
atmosphere outside of the filming which
ultimately lends itself to creating
more of a a dynamic relationship on set
and in the scenes
and we didn't have that on this
unfortunately hopefully if we
are lucky enough to get renewed for
season two it will
the protocols will be uh more relaxed
and will be able to do more social
things as a group
ducks stick together right yeah so let's
see it
show me the flying v all right and do
you hear from some of the original
mighty ducks are they like
dude you got a spot for me there is an
episode where some of the
original ducks participate they come
back i'm not at liberty to say which
ones
okay but they do come back have fun
coach and it was interesting
to see these kids who are now in their
40s
who are now older than i was when we did
the first
film it's interesting to see how uh yeah
i mean it's
30 years is it's a long time even though
look you had to flip the story a little
bit it still really worked in that true
like mighty ducks theme you felt it felt
authentic what was it like working with
this group
the themes of all the films is is the
underdog is the marginalized the
the kids that don't get invited to
participate
and and it was all about being inclusive
and i think that
this series even more so than the films
deals with inclusivity
and and and inviting the marginalized
to the party and be a part of of
something that you know
a team that normally they wouldn't have
been wouldn't have been invited to
let's start our own team look at this
your first teammate i would not be an
asset physically i have more of a
podcast body we're hearing rumors of a
young guns three
what can you tell me uh yeah i would say
that
while i still have great affinity for
independent film i think it's time to to
get back to work and and give
give audiences what what they want i'm a
big believer in environmental scanning
and you know i spent a lot of time out
in the world talking to folks
in the central corner of the country and
they would say to me hey man
you know we want to see you get back to
work we want to see you do gordon bombay
we want to see you billy the kid again
what are you doing get to work and so
that's what i'm doing i'm gonna get to
work
and and we're gonna we're gonna give the
people what they want you know for a lot
of us
our movie going experience had a lot to
do with you
when we grew up and watching you in
those backpack movies so
we've grown with you and now your
grandpa
how is that i'll tell you what i've seen
from a distance i've seen my
granddaughter
a couple of times this week watch her
run down the street
and and it's it's something else there
really aren't words to describe what
what it feels like to to be a
grandparent unless you know
those who are know exactly what it is
although
you know there's a part of me that still
feels like i'm you know 25 years old so
it's like
it's hard to embrace that